it's so funny because I've never
experienced that kind of show business
which is a huge bulk of Show Business
movies is making something when you're
producing it and directing it it's
you're it's years go into it yeah and
I've always been in the let's make it
today and get it on TV tonight yeah and
cabbie might shout something at me the
next day and then it but there's no time
to think about it because then you're
making the next thing
so I've never quite understood this the
film business fascinates me and what
little I've seen of it it looks
incredibly difficult and I understand
why I'm not part of it
you need you need a lot of you know you
need a lot of patience and a planning
and yeah I'm happy to get at bats like
that to me is what's fun right now like
just keep because what you were able to
build on The Daily was a sense of sort
of a greater thing that has a legacy
right so I think that when you're doing
these one-offs like every few years yes
it can feel
like oh my God there's so much pressure
on this one thing to work oh you know
and this is it and now I'm actually
settling just because I'm old I guess
I'm settling oh yeah yeah the idea that
like actually okay I if I if I can do
keep going they'll I will create a body
of work which you were able to do well
that was always that's always and then
the body will be you know what's left in
the Legacy and it won't it there won't
be this intense pressure to like always
I don't know I don't even know what the
pressure is anymore though too I'm sort
of like does it need I mean it needs to
make its money back I don't want anybody
to be like yeah and I and I don't want
to be boring that's the main thing I
don't want more people you don't have to
worry about that I don't think you have
to worry about that but is this because
it's funny you've achieved
so much and and and and in different
ways
but just talking to you I can feel
that you are you're tough and you're
tough on yourself probably tougher on
yourself than anybody I mean I think
that that's true yeah yeah I do also the
i in my mind I'm like you give yourself
Grace you give yourself Grace which I am
trying to do to it more of like give
myself
Grace because I do think the the guilt
and pressure of being a working mom too
is like it's real unfortunately in our
society and so I'm truly bringing myself
a sense of like
yeah it's okay I I really enjoy getting
to collaborate and make things with
people it's really fun I love
entertaining people I love making people
laugh and if I get to do that it's like
it's it's a privilege it's an honor it's
all the things that is it's also really
hard work and it also always takes me
away from other things I also like to do
like go into my kids basketball game you
know and so just making sure I don't
call it balance because I think that's
but there is no bound yeah when people
say what is that there is no balance I
don't know what that means I mean I just
in other words I'm just trying to
uh likes be my the best version of
myself so that's being creative doing
the collaboration
having fun with what I'm doing like you
know taking advantage of the the the the
um relationships I've made along the way
you know and and and hopefully grow
planting seeds that can grow later so
that this can keep going you know like
that's what I think about like the big
picture stuff but at the end of the day
I also um just trying when I when it
isn't great because sometimes it's not
great or I'll have a bit like a bad day
or a you know and by the way when I
watch cooking bear I'm like
there's still things like God damn it
why'd I cut that liner oh I should have
cut that like it's still not exactly
right but I like the idea that there's
at some point pencils down and you just
go like well I did the best I could do
with the time and money that I had and
the resources and the people and the da
da da and that's the grace I don't want
to talk to an artist who uh says no I
nailed it I mean nothing can be no
that's that's not no that's not the way
it is you can always hear something or
see something I want to bring up quickly
Ray Liotta who's one of my all-time
favorites and this must have been was
this the very last thing that he that he
worked on
um I I I'm not 100 sure so I don't know
well he went to the Dominican Republic
where he passed away to do another
project and I don't know how much he'd
actually shot of that before he passed
but I got to know him a bit just over
the years interviewing him and uh I mean
obviously you get to know him from
Goodfellas and that's such an iconic
role and um then when you talk to him
and he's just shrugging and being
self-effacing you can't you can't handle
it because you think no no no no you
know I I um
I think it's okay to say this I went to
like a memorial for him after he passed
away and I thought what was so sweet
about it was that the guys that were
there like his best friends who are were
like from high school yeah in Jersey
yeah like you know they're like they're
just the guys that he's always known
that that know him as like kind of sweet
and you know that's right it's Ray and
like he had a dream and he was in that
you know and he thought he was gonna go
to Hollywood and like they're all still
like and he did it you know and he was
like I'm doing it like like it's just
this beautiful sense that he
kind of really appreciated it and knew
where he was from and loved doing it and
all of those things
it says a lot about people that have
that kind of success and there's but
they're still good friends with people
they knew in high school college grade
school yeah I've cut all those people
out but
so what what why you were just as soon
as you went on TV you were like well hey
what's the point I had to cut them loose
you know can't have that those guys
hanging around but you just said it says
a lot about someone oh no it does I'm a
terrible person oh okay I just wanted to
make sure I understood what you were
saying okay I can't hang out with those
Brookline creeps
[Laughter]
do you go back a lot do you go back to
Massachusetts
um not as much as I want to I just got a
I just got a suite at the Garden
nice for Madonna nice I'm very excited
yeah so I will go back I'm going to
bring all my my cousins you know the
love all that I have so much my sisters
my other sisters how many how many are
there how many sisters well I'm the
oldest of four okay yeah so I don't have
that big of a family right but my mom is
from seven and my dad's from eight so I
have a lot of cuts I have a lot of first
cousins right
and then we'll be long we're going to
have a blast where I'm taking them all
to the sweet at the Garden that's
fantastic well thank you for thank you
for inviting me I'll be there as well
I didn't hear the invitation I don't
know if you are you are you a Madonna
fan I mean I feel like I would say I get
down to some Madonna you know School
hits you know it was never in my
wheelhouse I think that's fair to say
Springsteen guy right that's your vibe
[Music]
Princeton I love Bruce Springsteen it
just wasn't during the uh I'm gonna say
I didn't I didn't go Whole Hog on the
Madonna phenomenon when it was happening
I appreciated it yeah and I think she
was uh a great uh showman yeah show
Person she's a show Person yeah and uh
and she certainly killed it and uh did
it you know so but it's just not quite
in my see I think like me and my gals
we're gonna lose our minds you know it
does like the soundtrack to our youth we
did
we did like a virgin and holiday and you
know the whole like a prayer and the
whole you see I was too old for that
yeah and uh yeah and that was like we
did like dance routines to it and we had
to do the moves you know this was MTV
she was like on the videos and we all
did she was like all the you know the
bracelets the rubber bracelets I mean
you know we worshiped her so yeah I'm
excited yeah anyway that that for sure
is I'll be home in the summer and I'll
be seeing Madonna
um how often do you go back I go back uh
when I whenever I can my parents still
live there yeah uh and uh most my family
lives within like 30 minutes of where I
grew up yeah so I go back every chance I
can get
um and then walk around and just
remember the old days there's the
there's Duncan there's I go to Duncan of
course I walk by the football field
where I had no involvement in football I
was wondering where that was going I go
to the old baseball field where I had no
involvement in baseball
we reminisce about not doing sports yeah
I reminisce about being in my room
studying that's the room I studied in
uh-huh and then what happened
then I took a nap and then studied some
more
they're not good stories um yeah and I
had a few scrapes in my day that was a
real rap scallion